unlv leading the way in groundbreaking
research making strides toward an
eventual cure for alzheimer's that is
the goal of course right now they're
still working on understanding the
disease and risk factors but as heather
mills shows us they've made a big step
forward
a team of neuroscientists at unlv have
strengthened the connection between
diabetes and alzheimer's essentially
laying the way for more research to
build on this discovery the number of
alzheimer's cases continues to grow
it's estimated to more than triple in
the next 20 to 30 years a startling
number according to the alzheimer's
association 6 million americans are
living with the disease from 2000 to
2019 deaths from alzheimer's increased
145 percent that's why jeff kinney the
chair of unlv's department of brain
health says it's critical to continue
research here inside his lab at unlv two
dozen scientists are working on just
that where we make the best progress is
where
we have several people with different
skill sets and those get fused together
now they're one step closer establishing
a stronger connection between diabetes
and alzheimer's by looking at elevated
blood sugar what we found is that if we
established a good hyperglycemic state
we would start to see changes in the
brain that are consistent with what's
seen
in patients with alzheimer's disease
that's step one a lot of this research
is actually trying to determine
how long someone is hyperglycemic does
it give rise to increasing the risk two
years into a federal grant and working
in tandem with other researchers kinney
says they hope to answer that question
because right now treatments for
alzheimer's disease just delay the
progression we want to solve this
i hope you'll join me next saturday for
the alzheimer's association's walk to
end alzheimer's there's still time to
sign up for yourself or better yet get a
team together it's happening at the las
vegas ballpark and the money raised goes
towards care support and research back
to you